if I told you about her the princess  without voice what would I say  [Music]  she deaf mute she can hear you you clean  that lab to get out this may very well  be the most sensitive asset ever to be  housed in this facility  you may think that thing looks human  stands on two legs right but we're  created in the Lord Jim you don't think  that's what the Lord looks like me  this creature is intelligent capable of  language of understanding emotions  [Music]  when he looks at me he doesn't know how  I am incomplete he sees me as I am  [Music]  the natives in the Amazon where's Adam  Oh God  get him out what are you talking about  no you need to take it apart learn how  I don't want an intricate beautiful  thing destroyed we could do nothing I'm  sorry  don't do this Eliza what is she sorry  don't do this that's not even human  if I told you about her what would I say  I wonder  [Music]  you  you